I've been talking now for several weeks
about how Donald Trump will have the
biggest non mandate of any recent press
it president we now know that Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote as many of
you know by somewhere around 2.8 million
votes Donald Trump winning the election
effectively because of 58,000 votes
across three swing states now how much
does the average American know about
this will Pew Research quizzed people on
whether or not they knew the results of
the election and most people got the
answers correct but not all you asked
three questions who won the electoral
vote who won the popular vote who won
your state so 75 percent of people knew
who won the popular vote uh
interestingly 25% did not know who won
the popular vote about 80% new I'm sorry
the electoral vote 75% knew who won the
electoral vote 25% did not know that
Donald Trump and won the electoral vote
now met some of those may not have known
what it means to say the electoral vote
they might have just not understood that
concept number two about 80% knew the
winner of their own States amazingly one
in five people surveyed did not know who
won their own state in last month's
presidential election and then nearly
thirty percent of respondents didn't
know who won the popular vote why well
there's been a huge disinformation
campaign around this through this
Breitbart wrote an article that spread
very quickly saying if you don't count
the quote coastal elites in other words
high population cities Trump actually
won the popular vote which is so absurd
because if you also don't count all of
those red states in the middle of the
country Hillary Clinton won the
electoral college so that was a really
weird article that spread very quickly
from Breitbart but these articles
clearly had an impact because when you
look at the partisan split on getting
that question right who won the
electoral vote Republicans were slightly
more likely than Democrats to know who
won the electoral vote but Democrats
were way more likely pat to know that
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote why
does this matter
well it matters for a few reasons number
one Donald Trump lost the popular vote
by a margin that is five times bigger
than the roughly 500,000 votes by which
George W Bush lost to Al Gore in the
popular vote in the year 2000 and that
has an impact in terms of when Democrats
start to get in the way of what Donald
Trump wants to do if Republicans don't
realize that Donald Trump was defeated
in the popular vote by Hillary Clinton
by a record margin they might say that
Donald Trump's a mandate is being
interfered with but the reality is Trump
has the biggest non mandate of a very
long time yeah I think a lot of people
just tuned in on election night and then
didn't follow up in the days after cuz
you saw on election night that the final
score was 306 22 32 yet an electoral
college and you sell this map of all
these red states in the middle of the
country states that are very sparsely
populated most of the population centers
are on the coast no doubt but if that's
all you're taking in of course you've
gotta thank the Trump one in this big
landslide and Trump has been fomenting
this idea as well by saying I had a
historic electoral college victory will
know you didn't you won the electoral
college by way less than President Obama
did in 2012 and way way way way way less
than President Obama one in 2008 so the
missing fair information campaign is
absolutely working